elsewhere on Capitol Hill House and
Senate committees questions social media
leaders about meddling in American
elections Facebook CEO Sheryl Sandberg
and Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey were asked
about foreign interference on the
platform's they expressed regret and
suggested major changes are needed we
were too slow to spot this and too slow
to act that is on us I believe we need
to question the fundamental exam
incentives that are in our product today
every time someone opens up our service
every time someone opens up our app we
are implicitly incentivizing them to do
something or not to do something and
that extends all the way to our business
and those answers that we get from
asking that question are going to create
massive shifts in how Twitter operates
and I also believe how our industry
operates wired editor-in-chief Nicholas
Thompson is a CBS News contributor Nick
good morning quite a bit of
introspection there on that topic
they're talking about sure where we
would support some regulation but the
right type of regulation what would that
look like I don't think there's any
serious regulation that could possibly
happen right now that they would support
on the other hand I think one of the big
takeaways from yesterday is there
finally was a good substantive
conversation between Congress and the
tech leaders where Congress seems to
understand social media and the tech
leaders talk back straight about it and
that is great and a step towards
sensible regulation one day I was struck
Nick by Jack Dorsey's comment we
implicitly incentivizing it needs to be
that though that social media platform
said hey we just put it out there people
do their thing but now he's saying we do
have a role implicit or explicit
absolutely that is one of the big
changes in the tech industry is
understanding that everything they do
shapes what we do and that was a real
interesting moment and it may actually
have tanked the stock because we got big
changes come and says Dorsey but I
thought it was very smart of him and I
was impressed at that moment quite a bit
why wasn't goggle there Google had said
they weren't coming but they
deliberately left an empty chair to to
highlight Google's not here in Facebook
and Twitter are I think a they want this
to look like a social media problem not
a search problem
I think be the top executives there
aren't really comfortable in that kind
of spotlight and they just decided the
risk reward wasn't worth it
I think was a mistake yeah on cue the
Attorney General and Justice Department
say they're gonna be talking with state
attorneys about search about whether
search is bias and you know it was a
pretty friendly hearing yeah Google
should have been there yeah well they
probably will be enough I don't have to
search for that thanks a lot